pas de salon nautique vient de s'ouvrir
porte de versailles à paris est de plus
en plus de marins considèrent leur
bateau comme une véritable résidence
secondaire il faut dire que ce n'est pas
plus cher qu'une maison et que les
constructeurs se sont adaptés il y a
désormais à bord beaucoup plus de
confort lave-vaisselle écran plasma et
design cosy et en plus chaque année on
peut changer de destination je lis un
bonbon philippe maire vous pensez voir
des bateaux en fait c'est le salon de
l'immobilier sur l'eau d'ailleurs comme
pour les appartements les constructeurs
affichent les plans et pour cause les
plaisanciers passe maintenant jusqu'à
trois semaines à bord alors les
chantiers s'adapte
exemple avec ce nouveau voilier en
navigation au près de marseille le
cockpit arrière a été pensé comme une
terrasse et l'accès à l'eau est facilité
grâce à des sièges escamotables
là on a une grande zone ouverte vers la
mer ce qui permettra un accès la
baignade sous voile on trouve aussi des
winch électrique
plus besoin d'avoir de gros bras pour
manoeuvrer d'ailleurs ce bateau a été
conçu pour jt - c'est-à-dire pour moins
se pencher l'autre changement c'est un
intérieur stores électriques écran
plasma une maison sur l'eau est prié la
table
la vaisselle le concept du bateau c'est
vraiment le couple qui va vivre à bord
qui va inviter ses amis qui va avoir ses
enfants ou ses petits enfants qui vont
venir mais vraiment le le concept c'est
de vivre à bord comme à la maison
d'avoir l'un une maison secondaire 2
chambres 2 petite salle de bains ont
trois pièces les pieds dans l'eau à
250000 euros
pourtant le carnet de commandes est
plein jusqu'en juillet